hi and welcome to episode number 38 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am Francisco and I'm here with my
colleague Mark Mandel hey Mark
hey Francis how are you doing today very
good very good very very happy to have a
repeating guest today yeah Paul Newson's
gonna be joining us again first time you
talked to us about storage but now it's
gonna be something totally different
yeah he apparently he changed themes for
a little bit I'm hoping he will come
back but yeah he's gonna be sharing what
he's being lately up to which is really
cool so yeah very very interesting
interview I was checking yeah that was
episode 14 episode 14 storage with Paul
Nielsen if he's a 38 all the stuff with
Paula Nielsen it's like if you divide it
by two it's exactly twice No okay anyway
so so yeah we're gonna be talking with
bonusing about his new role as an SRE
and what is to be a necessary and then
we have the question of the week we
cheese guess what again a little bit
about kubernetes no not at this time
well actually Google container engine so
yes it is kubernetes again it is about
how to upgrade your kubernetes your
container engine okay clusters cluster
to newest versions and how to do that so
but before that we're gonna be talking
about two cool things of the week yeah
we have a couple of really great
announcements first of all we released a
whole new API under our cloud machine
learning spectrum cloud natural language
API which is really cool and the cloud
speech API is they kind of work hand in
hand it's pretty sweet you can send I
basically audio to it and it's able to
basically take the text to go speech to
text which is really awesome but also do
things like cinnamon analysis entity
recognition syntax analysis to do like
way more stuff that I can understand
about the English
language in various other languages as
well and break it down into like verbs
and adverbs and like what's important
and what's not and do all sorts of other
fun things with it yeah it is really
cool and one of the things that I really
love is these entity analysis which
sounds kind of abstract but it is able
to tell you things like if you have a
text that says oh yeah last year I went
to the Big Apple it will tell you oh the
Big Apple you mean New York it will
actually make those links which is
pretty amazing it is not just like basic
text analysis is way more than that
it is it is pretty impressive it is
really impressive the other thing that
we announced is like a whole new region
yes cuz why not why not let yeah we
don't have enough data centers or
computers so we now have a region in
u.s. West yep and and we're gonna be
talking a little bit more about that
during the interview because apparently
our colleague Paul was somehow related
to this yeah yeah very interesting it's
pretty cool I'm just reading now that
initial testing shows that users were in
Vancouver Seattle Portland San Francisco
and Los Angeles can expect to see a 30
to 80 percent reduction in latency nice
that's pretty good
how come about that excellent so that
seems like some cool stuff um but why
don't we do some other cool things like
go talk to Paul yeah it's good with that
it sounds good to me so I'm very happy
to introduce Paul noose and hey Paul how
are you doing I'm doing great how are
you very happy to have you back to the
podcast we we have the along time ago
when you used to be a developer advocate
to talk about storage I didn't even know
what episode was that it's really early
yeah I think it was a single-digit yeah
years ago I think a lifetime ago
and now you're back you're not a
developer advocate anymore so who are
you what do you do hi Paul
so my name is Paul Newson and I am
indeed still a developer advocate but
I'm doing this really cool rotation
program called Mission Control where I
get to be a Google sre which is a site
reliability engineer for approximately
six months and I get to learn what
psyche reliability engineering is all
about it's something I've been really
care
about for a long time have been at
Google now a little over six years I
think and for the first few years I was
here I was a software engineer on cloud
storage and at the end of my time there
I was I was really curious about Sree
and I nearly did a Mission Control
rotation but instead I decided to turn
left instead of right and I became a
developer advocate and ended up on a
team with with you folks and so a couple
a few months back I was having a great
conversation with Brian Dorsey who you
both obviously know about how difficult
it is to talk about reliability with our
customers as a developer advocate I mean
it's it's hard to it's hard to describe
like what is the conversation you can
have about that and I realized you know
what I really like to be able to do is
talk about site reliability engineering
at Google but I just don't feel like I
know enough to have that conversation
like I didn't feel like I could really
represent the whole you know site
reliability engineering philosophy and
approach to reliability really well so
then I hit on the idea of maybe it maybe
now's the time for me to do this mission
control rotation and really learn what
this is all about
so that's that's what I did and I
started on that in May and I guess it's
July now so I'm a couple of months in
and so it's still still just the
beginning one of the things that that
I'm excited to do while I'm on this
rotation is write about it on the Google
cloud platform blog so I did that a
couple of weeks ago I think and now I'm
here talking to you guys on the podcast
yeah that blog post was amazing yeah
they loved it absolutely so all right
let's find out so what is a site
reliability engineer so site reliability
engineering is to quote Ben trainer it's
what happens when you put a software
engineer in charge of an Operations
function so the the history of the term
he's the one who coined coined the
phrase because they wanted to have a
they wanted to have a phrase or a name
or a title for what do we call these
software engineers who are building
features into the product but are
instead concerned with making sure the
product can scale up and making sure the
product is real
and doing all of that in a sustainable
way that doesn't burn people out and
that's that's what site reliability
engineering was meant to capture other
companies may call it s re they may call
it something else
broadly it is an Operations function we
think we add a little twist to it that
at least was novel at the time DevOps is
also sort of mixed in there it's it's
all it's all kind of in the we're not
building features we're talking about
how you how you do something like this
reliably and well and scalably so that's
kind of what you know not so brief
nutshell site reliability engineering is
about yeah that it's a role that I
really like at Google because it's it's
I think very different to what all the
people expect from DevOps like I know
that SOE people write lots of code like
the deal with a great amount of code but
my favorite thing about them is you have
sre jackets I don't have an SRE jacket
yeah you should you better get one those
are amazing well I'll tell them you said
so francisc so that they have to give me
one because you said it publicly on the
podcast that that I should get one yeah
maybe that's just what I need
but yeah the there's a there's a badge
it's a leather jacket you can choose
your style there's a few different
styles and there's a badge that you can
put on it which is modeled after the
badges that they would have at NASA
mission control and two for each mission
they would have a mission patch for each
mission which I think the astronauts
would wear and then they would have a
mission patch for the mission control
people as well and so somebody came up
with the idea long ago that Wow it'll be
really cool to have like that style of
patch on a jacket just to show hey we're
s eries we keep Google up yeah that's
already cool and the bunch has a slogan
yes and I'm not gonna I'm not going to
try and pronounce the Latin because come
on try no come on you're from Canada
they speak Latin up there
but it's it's based on the motto of Jean
Jean Krantz coin for Mission Control
which I believe is man you think I'd
have this by heart because hope isn't
that a strategy is it that well that is
that is a different one hope oh there's
not a strategy is a slogan is there is
an unofficial essary slogan but this one
is tough and competent okay cool that's
that's the that was the Mission Control
slogan and that's what's on the actual
patch but hope is not a strategy is is
also one of the things that is an SRE
slogan and you know the the philosophy
there being is what yeah anything that
can go wrong will go wrong pretty much
and hoping it won't go wrong is not is
not a viable strategy when you do things
at the scale that Google does because at
some point like if you have enough
servers doing enough things in enough
data centers then something that happens
once in a million is happening
constantly that Google because we're
doing millions and millions and millions
of things all the time so those very
very rare bugs that might hit a small
service once a year could hit us once a
day or once a minute so you know hope is
not a strategy is is a very important
slogan for sre sometimes you even get
struck by lightning four times in a row
yes and and then it happens a second
time yeah but but I wouldn't think I
love about that is I just know that
there is probably an SRE or a hardware
UPS person somewhere who's like alright
now we need to protect us against tank
strikes like there's someone with that
plan with a document saying this is what
we need to prevent against going forward
so you can't predict every failure
that's that's an interesting thing right
so what you what you want to do is is
have sort of a culture and a process for
dealing with whatever it is that comes
up because you can't predict everything
like you're gonna you're going to in
fact if this job would be extremely
boring if all we ever did was respond to
the
problems over and over again it's
actually an explicit goal that we should
never have the same problem twice
because we had it once already we did a
post-mortem on it we figured out why it
happened and we fixed whatever that was
right so every time the pager goes off
it should be a new and novel thing
you've never seen before so that's what
you have to practice for you can't
practice for the specific scenario you
have to work on things that are generic
across problems across incidents like
you need a good instant response sort of
method that people understand I can't
speak to that right now because I
haven't learned that part I I'm
currently embedded with the Google
compute engine SRE team and I might one
of my goals for this quarter is to be
trained up to go on call so hopefully I
can go on call next quarter but
currently I don't understand the
Incident Response process that we have
here so I'm not going to pretend to you
know say something intelligent about it
here on the podcast but I know it exists
and I see it in action and I watch I was
thinking this morning actually you know
anticipating this interview and I was
thinking you know I feel like we should
have t-shirts that say keep calm and sre
because because it's kind of this this
very like even when stuff is going wrong
people are pretty chill because it's
like this is this is the job and people
are set up to succeed in it you have the
resources you have the backup you're not
out there by yourself
and and it happens all the time it's
kind of like kind of like being on on
coal for like you're part of emergency
services right
your job is to put out fires or your job
is to save people like your job is to
basically sit there and say okay things
are gonna go wrong all the time and our
job is to make sure that they go as best
as they can
and that's that's a really that's half
the job I would say and and this is a
really really important thing to
understand about SRA and probably I
would say more broadly modern operations
of large-scale services so let's do a
thought experiment right you ship a
service that runs and it's running on
ten servers and you need to pay one
person full-time to do sort of manual
things to those servers to keep them up
you know we call this we call that toil
where it's something that you do it's
necessary it's important but basically
what you're doing is you're returning
the service to a good state and now you
have now you you get lots of new
customers and you have 20 servers now
you need two people to do that assuming
your toil scales with the number of
servers you have then let's say you
don't add servers let's say you have
these really sharp developers who come
up with these awesome new features and
they deploy these new features and that
increases the surface area of the
product the product got bigger even
though it's like not more servers or
more users so now you're growing in
multiple dimensions if you need to scale
the number of people doing toil on your
service with the number of servers or
the number of users or the amount of
traffic or the amount of features then
eventually you're going to have an ops
team which is like unsustainably huge
like you won't be able to hire enough
people to take care of your service so I
would almost say the more important role
of sre you know we're very we're well
known for like we carry the pager for
the services we support we are the we
are on the front lines right that's
where everybody thinks of even
internally at Google usually that's what
everyone thinks of when they think of
SRE
but we spend less than half of our time
doing that and we spend more than half
of our time writing code and doing
engineering work so that the toil does
not scale with the size of the service
because like let's take Google compute
engine as an example
our usage is growing that's probably not
a secret and we are constantly launching
new features just look at the cloud
platform blog so we're growing in all
the dimensions that you could imagine
the product is growing much much much
faster than the size of the SRE team
supporting it in fact the size of the
SRE team supporting it is roughly
constant if you look at the feature set
that one team is is supporting so how is
it possible that the service can get so
much bigger and the team that is sort of
on the front lines on call for it
doesn't grow
well that's because that team is
constantly doing work to make the
service easier - easier to keep up
easier to monitor easier to so that
things that might have happened a year
ago that required manual intervention
just happened now we have programs for
that like if it's something that you can
do without you know really discerning
human judgment you just write a program
for that and then it does it for you if
you know what the solution is you just
write a program for it and then you
deploy that program and then you make
sure that programs up that reminds me of
the joke if you're not good at we place
you with a script basically that is your
job
exactly we want to and we don't want to
hire more s eries to do the same thing
that we're doing we want to write
scripts for what we're doing today and
then you know go do something
interesting tomorrow that we haven't
done before so talking about things that
are interesting you said that you're not
on coal and that you're doing all the
things one of those things is actually a
free amazing thing it is a new region on
Google cloud platform that's that's
correct I I had the privilege of being
peripherally involved in the unveiling
of our new u.s. West one region this
past week which was which was a really
great experience and I want to be super
clear here that many many many other
people did tons and tons of tons of work
over many weeks to actually bring up a
new region like you know servers need to
actually arrive at places and be put in
racks and
you know all kinds of services need to
be turned up and monitored on those
things and then the very very very last
step is we sort of flick a switch and
and now it appears to the world and
everybody can see all this hard work
that's that's happened over a period of
time so my part in that was I I got to
be somewhat involved in flipping the
switch so to speak because something
that I've been working on was how we do
configuration changes for Google compute
engine you know hey let me let me step
back a second any change you make to
your service carries some risk right if
you want a 100% reliable service never
change anything and then it won't break
right but that's not what customers want
customers want new regions customers
want new features we need to do these
things because even if we tried to stay
static our customers wouldn't they would
bring new workloads to us so we're
constantly modifying and changing the
system and the interesting part is how
do you do that as safely as possible
right so I was I was involved with all
right we're gonna unveil this be reached
and how do we want to do this like what
are the series of steps who want to go
through what are the checks and balances
along the way and how long do we want it
to take things like that and so you know
I got to be involved in defining that
process which was mostly just writing
down stuff I'd learned from all the
people around me in the past couple of
months but I just happened to be the
person who was you know collecting that
information then presenting it as a plan
and then people much more knowledgeable
and experienced than I said yes this
plan makes sense go do it and then I
wasn't even the one flipping the switch
because if you're going to modify a
production service the person who should
be doing that is the person who's on
call so I essentially presented this
plan to the people who happen to be on
call who happened to be like carrying
the pager at that moment in time said
all right here's how we're going to do
this and then they went and did it
so it was lots of fun I really enjoyed
it and I'm kind of now I want to get
more involved in how we turn up regions
and and be involved in one you know from
beginning to end
you know we've announced that we're
gonna do a lot of these over the next
year or so so there should be lots of
opportunity for me to get involved in
that cool I have a smoke question for
you from earlier because I'm actually
just curious you talked about doing a
rotation through SRA do people normally
do rotations like do they come and they
go or is it a permanent position how
does that normally work so sre is
usually a permanent position but we have
this thing called the Mission Control
Program because you know a lot of lot of
software engineers who have worked at
other companies come to Google and they
caught a Google as a software engineer
and they may be interested in how to run
a service at at really high scale kind
of like I was when I came here but they
may have come from a culture where
operations is not as well regarded and
where the operations function is not as
well supported as it is at Google so
this so they may be hesitant to become
an SRE they might think man I I don't
want to carry the page or that just
sounds like it's gonna be like draining
it's gonna take over my whole life so
this is a way for them to come into sre
learn all about it get trained up carry
the pager and see if this is something
that they like to do and what they what
often they discover along the way is Wow
real engineering work happens here like
I'm still writing code most of the time
but I'm also doing these really cool
things with these huge systems that like
I can't believe they let me touch this
stuff is fantastic and and then they
have the experience of carrying the
pager and they realize oh Google
understands how to make being on-call a
sustainable thing that doesn't ruin your
life right we have the advantage of
being a global company so the Google
compute engine team that I'm embedded
with for example is in our Seattle
office but we have a sister team in the
London office which is conveniently
about eight time zones away so when
we're sleeping they're on call and when
they're sleeping we're on call you know
it makes it far more sustainable than
the typical your the ops guy hears
pager it could ring at any time good
luck to you yeah I still have you know
stress-induced dreams of getting woken
up at four o'clock in the morning to
battle some fire that happens on some
survey right and and that's that's not
how we do it here because it's not
sustainable the our management in in sre
views s erease as a rare and valuable
resource that you know it's hard to hire
into this position and once we have
somebody in this position we want to
take care of them and make sure that
they want to stay in that position
because we can't possibly hire enough
this is the other reason why we need to
make sure that we don't need to scale
the number of s our ease with the size
of our services because we couldn't
possibly hire enough if that's what we
were doing so you know we have we have
guidelines around how many incidents an
on-call ER should be taken care of in a
particular shift then if it goes above a
certain threshold that's a warning sign
that this service is now not sustainable
and we need to stop focusing on features
or shift our focus from like launching
new features to make this a more
sustainable service because if we don't
it's gonna run away right like these
these feel like sort of the slippery
slopes if you once you get a certain
velocity of you know unmanageability
then suddenly you're spending all of
your time trying to deal with the
unmanageability and you can't make
progress anymore so we have these
metrics which we review on a regular
basis
how many incidents are we seeing per
shift you know are our engineers
spending a majority of their time
actually doing work to make the service
more maintainable more sustainable
versus just doing manual toil and so
coming back to the Mission Control
rotation you get into SRE
and you realize wow google has figured
out how to make this work and not only
that this is fun this is rewarding I
like the people I'm doing it with this
is great I want to keep doing this I'm
not scared of it anymore so roughly half
the engineers software engineers who
come through like and software engineers
from the development team who previously
had been working on launch
new features roughly speaking who comes
through Mission Control rotation they
choose to stay as a series after the
rotation and that becomes their
permanent job there's other people who
are just hired straight into sre because
they were doing SOE like work at another
another company or maybe they just take
the plunge right and they say you know I
really want to get my hands on these
huge services and they make the plunge
but to answer your question the the
Mission Control rotation program is
officially a rotation program that lasts
for six months but really what it is is
a chance to experience sre and then you
get to make a choice at the end SOE
would probably love to have you stay but
you can always go back to you know
typical development position as well or
develop where advocacy or an or in my
case developer advocacy we want you back
I have a couple of questions regarding
this the first one is you said that you
you still read a lot of code and and you
know my question now what language oh
well you'll be happy to hear France ask
that I am currently learning go there
you go because the the system that I
will be enhancing with new features is
written and go nice and then and go is a
very popular language among s eries for
all reasons I probably don't need to
tell you France s nothing than just
being awesome you know it's also very
fast but it's it's because previously
Python was was very popular among a
series mostly because of that really
fast iterative development and with go
you get that but it's not an interpreted
language which personally I'm gonna
expose my bias now I really like
languages that actually compile to
something and where types have meaning
yeah and I'm not getting type errors at
runtime my personal bias you know use
the tools you like but you know I'm a C
programmer at heart so go makes me very
very happy and you were saying that it
is hard to do higher a series and
that is why when Google hires a Sri
SRI's that we try to keep them as happy
as possible what are the skills you
think are the most important to have to
become a necessary or to be a good
essary well I'm gonna try and accurately
repeat things I've heard others say
because I don't feel I'm really
qualified to give my own answer to this
question but we sort of have two types
of people who typically come in an
interview for sre and and are successful
and become successful as a Suri's one is
what you would expect from pretty much
applying to software and so for
engineering role at Google same skillset
you you are your software engineer you
know how to write code you know how to
architect systems hopefully you have
some distributed systems knowledge those
people can come in and and and become
successful SaaS and in fact most people
who are coming through the mission
control program fit that profile then
there's then there's sort of what they
call the system engineer that's what
they call it and these are people who
may not have the formal software
engineering background like maybe they
didn't graduate from a computer science
or a computer engineering program but
they have been architecting and building
and operating large-scale systems as
part of their work and that part of
their career and they come in with a
particular mindset and a set of
experiences which is super valuable and
and so there's a path for them as well
within within SRE both in terms of being
hired and progressing in their career
and what we've found is that it really
doesn't matter which of those two
profiles you meet like these people who
may not have the formal software
engineering or computer science
background you know they're still
writing code today lots of people write
code you don't have that background and
there's lots of people who do it very
well who don't have that background and
they come in and they make you know
equally good contributions but they also
tend to bring a set of experiences and
knowledge of sort of low level systems
and often networking
which is super useful to to SRA and then
these two sort of populations mix
together and everyone learns from each
other and it's fantastic cool all right
well we're starting to run out of time
unfortunately this is a great
conversation but before we run off is
there anything you'd like to like
mention or touch on or something we may
have missed in our questions you want to
say let's see oh yeah there's a couple
things one is you know take everything
you've heard here with a grain of salt
this is obviously just my opinion based
on a few weeks of hanging out with these
people and I'm not an expert on SRE
so you know please please bear that in
mind but there's also a couple of other
resources I'd like to point people
towards @sr econ 14 I believe and
trainer gave a talk where he walked
through the principles of sre and a
great deal of what I've told you here
today I learned from watching that talk
and other talks like it so you know if
this is an interesting topic to you it
would be very well worth 45 minutes of
your time to go watch Ben trainer talk
about this instead of listening to me
and then if that really wets your
appetite and you really want to go deep
there was a book released recently
called site reliability engineering and
that would be that's a great read I'm
still working my way through it I don't
know all the material in it and I think
there's a lot of good wisdom in there it
was written by people who are s eries at
Google it's sort of a series of essays
on a series of important topics I think
there's a lot of really good knowledge
in there so that would be a fantastic
and fantastic resource and then finally
if you are interested in this topic but
don't have the time to read the book or
can't set aside the 45 minutes just keep
watching the Google cloud platform blog
because I hope to publish more little
nuggets of my experience there in a way
that won't take you hours and hours to
consume where I can introduce some of
the concepts and some of the aha moments
I've had along the way and maybe you can
share because I'm on this journey from
not understanding this stuff to
hopefully understanding this stuff and I
hope to publish some of those
moments along the way when I have these
realizations about what's important and
what's cool and maybe you can you know
vicariously share in those with me on
that on the blog excellent
that is great we'll have we have links
to every single one of those things that
you said in the show notes absolutely
but uh yeah Paul thanks so much for
coming to join us today it's been an
absolutely fascinating conversation it's
my pleasure and maybe we can do this
again maybe in the new year after I've
had my rotation and I can correct all of
the mistakes that I made in this
interview and add more detail I think
that I think that's a deal done yep
right thank you so much you're welcome
thanks good talk to you guys yes that
was an amazing conversation with Paul
thanks so much to him for coming in
joining us today I I'd learned so much
more about s eries than I think I even
imagined I would so yeah awesome
I'm very happy that he was the one
proposing that he will come back before
he finished his rotation because he's
totally doing that yes yeah absolutely
we'll have him back again that's for
sure a hundred percent but why don't I
get into our question of the week which
is looking at when you have a container
engine cluster set up on gke obviously
new versions of communities come up and
you want to upgrade to them how do you
handle that like I'm a part of it sort
of automated part of it's not how do you
manually process that three will make
sure you have the least amount of
downtime and sort of manage that within
your schedule for your application so
yeah that is a question that many people
ask quite often so one of our co-workers
Terry Ryan wrote a blog post about it
and we'll have a link on the show notes
as as usual but basically the answer is
okay so the master of your the masters
will be upgraded automatically at some
point not too long after the new version
has been released the master will be
rebooted and you don't need to care
about this everything just happens is
invisible it's magic and it's beautiful
now we don't do this for notes why well
because imagine that you're getting a
huge amount of traffic in that at that
moment we decide that is a perfect
moment to restart your notes not great
so you can restart them either by just
restarting them you will get a new node
and then you node will have the new
version of Goodman off career
or also you have you have a way to
upgrade manually yeah there's a series
of g-cloud commands like upgrade
commands and you can also do it through
the web interface as well
they actually it says in our
documentation it says generally you want
to be upgrading in a timely manner nodes
that are more than two minor versions
behind the master may not work properly
so it should be upgrading your nodes but
it yeah the blog post sort of covers the
the several different ways you can do it
and how you can get accurate upgrades
happen in a timely fashion it also has
some discussion of things like node
pools and whatnot what to do when you
have like volumes mounted and how to
manage that and that's another minor
points as well it's pretty pretty
comprehensive yeah I really like the
fact that the easiest way to upgrade a
node node tool or even a master is to
just go to the information on google on
the console and you click on upgrade
available and that's it yeah that is
incredibly simple but of course if you
want to do it through the G cloud so you
can write your own script or whatever
that is totally doable and very simple
and we also explained how to do it on on
the block list
absolutely so before we run away I know
that you're not necessarily travelling
anywhere but you have a new video series
yes that is true so yeah there's I'm
sure them some of you know mpj from fun
fun function so basically I'm just
copying him and doing slightly different
things but inspired by I'm totally
inspired by him so if you don't know him
go check it out he's he's on many videos
and basically what I'm trying to do is
just me hacking on stuff or the first
episode is actually not even hacking is
I saw some code in the wild on github
and decided that it needed some code
review so I just it's a video of myself
doing a 35-minute code review talking
about how to improve code code and the
name is just for funk
oh nice cuz funk like function and go
yeah yeah I'm pretty pretty one yeah
excellent
alright well I will be well I'll
actually be in the middle of Australia
when this episode comes out but after
that I will be at PAX dev and what is
that late August
and then mid-september I will be at
Strange Loop hopefully doing something
there haven't quite worked out what yet
nice strange slope is a really good
conference is a really cool conference
they have on sessions there so if anyone
has any suggestions for an unsession
that they might want to see please send
it throughout I'd be interested in maybe
putting something together based on that
cool well I think we're out of time so
I'm just gonna thank you again for
taking the time to interview our awesome
colleague böck and thank you for sending
time with me as well and thank you to
all our listeners for listening guys
absolutely and I will see you all next
week
see ya